so when you sign up for one of these
director consumer tests you give some
information to the company and they post
you a box with a little tube inside and
they ask you to send back a saliva
sample I did it together with some
friends and we all got together to
dribble into these tubes and try to fill
them to that line and it doesn't seem
like much but it's actually when you're
trying to produce that amount of saliva
on demand it's kind of a disgusting
thing to do so after you send back your
spit sample you have to register the
sample online you have the option of
answering some of the questions
regarding your health history and
lifestyle which will be further used for
research purposes a few weeks later you
got an email that they tell you that
they received your sample they've run
the genetic tests that they do and you
can log into the website to get access
to your information for the first time
the information was present in two forms
one is my role DNA data and the other
one is the service trying to help me to
interpret those data so it has the
ancestry component and also a long list
of different type of disease and then
whether more likely to get the disease
own less likely compared to the average
population